hey guys Ryan right here we're going to
watch the trailer today the final
trailer for The Hunger Games Mocking J
part one well said a lot of [__] about
this movie already I'm sure this trailer
is just going to resolidify how good
this movie
looks no one else can do this but her
she W be able to handle it the game's
destroyed her let us see what the
Capital District
12 they're coming candage they kill
everyone
[Music]
de everything prepare to pay the
ultimate
price oh
[__] I have a message for President
Snow if we burn
you burn with
[Music]
us I am so looking forward to this I
mean it looks really dramatic and heavy
but damn does it look like a moving
pcture if you know what I mean Jennifer
Lawrence she's just going to [__]
rocket I love that line if we burn
forgot the rest of the line oh then
he'll bur with something like that damn
it but yeah this trailer is just
resolidifying that this movie is going
to be the [__] dude that's the Hunger
Games man I love the first two and
Philip Seymour Hoffman's in this [__]
Philip Seymour Hoffman it's my
impression well anyway guys thanks for
telling me that trailer was out I mean
yeah it did exactly what I thought it
would do just resolidify how cool this
movie looks if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
where um
videos are
posted and now a lot of people have been
requesting shout outs so to keep up with
it we've created a facebook.com/ theal
reject shoutouts page in order to get a
shout out just say something cool or
interesting I don't care what it is and
then yeah Jimmy steens hey man I'm not
asking for a shout out cuz I got one of
your deleted Whiplash trailer reaction
but can you give me another one if you
like yeah dude sure Jimmy steens I'll
give you a shout out dude Jimmy that's a
cool name I want a guy named Jimmy
Japanese had long ass nose hair freak
but Jimmy steens detective Jimmy you
know what man I think I gave you a shout
out already that's right yeah I redid
your shout out you [__] Adam
Penning guys I request a shout out is it
will make me as moist as wet sponge
speaking of moist every time I watch a
show I wee a little what you said I find
funnier than when I cover my brother's
bed and use cat litter Adam Penning this
is one of the most confusing yet most
disgusting comments I've ever read I'm
glad we can make you as moist as a wet
sponge I know what it's like to make
someone as moist as a wet sponge believe
me woo ah yeah it's cool that you piss a
little bit every time you watch one of
our shows because you know what man my
goal is to make people pee as much as
possible urine you know there's
something orgasmic about like when you
really have to go to the bathroom and
then you pee it feels like an orgasm
maybe even a little better Kevin C would
love a shout out for me and my film
reviewing website thanks Kevin thedragon
eyes.com Kevin Cy he's a movie critic I
have seen all of his reviews they are
okay they're not like mine mine are
perfect but his they're they're okay
sorry Kevin I got to uh eliminate the
competition so maybe your reviews are
good I don't know I actually haven't
seen them so it's not fair for me to
judge but if you think think you can go
up against this
guy you're wrong Jeremy Johns a even got
something on me
man no he's the best Kevin
Cy I hope that I could make you PP as
well